Il semble que les X-Men viennent d'arriver sur les lieux.
Poussez-vous !
Que tout le monde se calme, les professionnels sont arrivés !
Je... Nous sommes les X-Men.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Mon travail !
C'est toi qui m'a dit que j'étais prêt.
J'étais pas d'accord avec toi et pourtant on est là tous les deux.
Essayons de mettre de côtés nos différences.
Comme disait Beyoncé : "S'il te plaît, s'il te plait, arrêtes de me tromper".
Hey, c'est le 5ème incident de la sorte.
Ce gamin mérite d'être derrière des barreaux, pas ici !
Russell doit être en soin intensif, pas en prison.
Je vous assure que tout est sous contrôle.
Il semble que vous contrôlez que dalle, Marty.
Votre prénom c'est Glenn n'est-ce pas ?
Daniel.
C'est moi qui pose les questions ici.
Laissez-moi parler au gamin.
Et toi, restes ici avec tes jolies lèvres.
- "Vous voulez mourir ?"
- Ce gamin est adorable.
Je sais même pas pourquoi j'ai pris des armes à pointes creuses sur moi.
"Je vais vous éclater les burnes !"
Des armes à pointes creuses ?
Ouaip... T'aurais dû apporter un Nerf.
Salut, toi !
Reculez ou...
Je tue Justin Bieber !
Ahah ! Il t'a appelé Justin Bieber !
Attends, attends !
Repose... ce truc que t'as dans les mains.
OK ? Parlons un peu.
Tu t'appelles Russell, c'est ça ?
Je m'appelle Firefist !
Firesfist... Wouah, c'est un super nom.
Et où ça brûle ?
Uniquement à la main où jusqu'au coude ?
Oh oh ! Définitivement jusqu'au coude !
Rends-toi tranquillement ou sinon...
C'est une phrase qui vient de RoboCop !
Mais ouais, RoboCop.
Restes là, tu nous fout la honte.
Ecoutes Firef... Fire...
C'est tellement ridicule. Désolé je peux pas le dire...
Oh....